c'est le neuvième art pardon qu'il va
nous intéresser à présent avec deux
poids lourds du secteur c'est un
véritable match qui va s'engager d'un
côté tintin personnage créé en 1929 par
georges remi et qui possédait de 1946 à
1993 un journal à son nom et puis de
l'autre spirou personnage créé en 1938
par robert velter popularisé par
franquin qui possède lui toujours un
journal à son nom depuis à la date de sa
naissance depuis 1938 la bibliothèque de
versailles propose de découvrir
justement une rétrospective sur ces deux
personnes âgées le 20 avril le
commissaire de l'exposition et donc avec
nous et pour être bien clair ce sont les
revues qui vous intéressent les
périodiques plus que les personnages on
va dire même les bandes dessinées qui en
ont découlé tout à fait on a pris le
parti dans cette exposition de mettre en
avant les deux revues qui pendant 40
voire 50 ans se sont répartis les grands
auteurs de bandes dessinées qui sont
devenus les auteurs emblématiques de la
bande dessinée aujourd'hui franco-belge
75 ans pour ce père au 65 ans pourtant
en saxe piroi survécu seul spir a
survécu bah oui
l'hebdomadaire est un journal compliqué
et et spirou a toujours gardé le cap
même s'il ya eu des creux même si elles
des vagues ils ont continué à tenir le
cap et un tas a décidé plutôt d'arrêter
mais les deux sont encore des maisons
d'édition qui ont d'à côté c'est du
puits de côté ses éditions du lombard et
les deux sont encore des des poids
lourds de l'édition de la bande dessinée
en france avec cette exposition vous
parlez de match retour alors c'est un
vrai duel qu'il ya eu pendant des
dizaines et des dizaines d'années entre
les deux sont déjà dans les cours de
récréation il fallait choisir on était
un temps où spéciaux exactement et ce
qui est amusant c'est que dans cette
exposition à la fin on a fait ce qu'on
appelle la galerie des illustres c200
dessinateurs qui ont dessinée spirou
donc à la fois le personnage mais aussi
ce qu'ils ont pensé de spirou et donc
ses 200 auteurs de bande dessinée ont
donné leur avis aussi plutôt tintin
plutôt spirou donc voilà il ya
différentes écoles et donc ça montre que
c'était un match mais un match culturel
ils sont plutôt proches finalement ces
deux personnages y sont tous les deux
journalistes ils mènent des aventures à
travers le monde entier blanc a pour
compagnon un petit chien milou l'autre
c'est un petit écureuil ils sont assez
proches finalement oui dans les ailes
des années 30 les années 40 aux ventes
et prolifique et ils ont développé
plutôt ses personnages aux tournées avec
un animal parce que la position de la
femme était plus compliqué donc on
n'avait pas s'il ya très peu de femmes
dans les personnages et spiro de tintin
un peu plus de ce prix en occasion après
mais tintin mais plutôt un personnage
emblématique où les femmes ont peu de
place puisqu'ils ont tous un compagnon
si c'est tentant capitanat d'orgueil qui
espère hausser plutôt fantasio sept mois
alors êtes vous plutôt tintin spirou je
vais forcément vous posez la question
est pour l'instant voici la réponse de
quelques saint quentinois micro trottoir
réalisé aujourd'hui
les deux les deux sur tout drôle tous
les deux sont drôles de préférence
particulière
parce que le bien est plutôt plus marrer
duration va même plutôt tintin mais je
ne sais pas que j'aime pas spirou mais
tintin je trouve ça un petit peu plus un
petit plus profond quoi un peu plus
intéressant voilà j'ai pas acheté ou
bien rabotés de vous répondre
honnêtement j'aime et les deux quand
j'étais enfant les deux mais c'est vrai
que c'était deux bandes dessinées
différent je pense qu'il y avait plus à
l'époque en tout cas de pour les plus
petits plus amusant on bande dessinée
pour spirou qui tintin ya plus de jeu
avec elle je crois de mémoire mais
maintenant un
hyper au père loïc toute la saga
espérons que j'ai connu dans ma jeunesse
c'est pour ça et j'adore tentera aussi
mais je préfère spirou c'est plus
spirituelle plus marrant plus
difficile de choisir entre tintin et
spirou d'ailleurs moi j'aurais pas su
répondre j'aurais pas su choisir entre
les deux personnages est pour vous moi
je déjà c'est donc un combat sur les
journaux donc ça comprend différentes
écoles on va dire l'école de spirou et
puis décline une école humoristique avec
des gros nez avec il ya eu lui qui lui
qui a eu besoin et pirlouit a eu
énormément de série est un teint était
pour une partie je dis pas pour
l'instant mais plus réaliste avec michel
vaillant alix voilà des dons qu'il y
avait les deux écoles les deux étaient
bourrés d'humour parce que tu sois
franquin que ce soit par exemple tibet
pour ricocher où il ya plein d'humour y
revoilà plein de choses et l'exposition
montre bien ce rapport entre les entre
les deux journaux et surtout la
prolifération de série qui sont cultes
aujourd'hui et qui sont nés dans ses
différentes revues parce que c'est
vraiment là que tout se passait pour la
bande dessinée franco belge il fallait
passer dans une de ces deux revues
auparavant pour ensuite espérer
exactement on ne passer que par là au
départ pour faire de la bande dessinée
on peut aimer les deux personnages où il
faut forcément choisir non il faut aimer
les deux il faut aimer les deux il faut
découvrir donc cette exposition on
envoie quelques images ça débute le 20
avril ça se termine le 13 juillet vous
avez le temps d'aller la découvrir que
qu'est ce que vous avez réussi à
regrouper sur place on l'a vu il ya
quelques planches il ya aussi alors il
ya des figurines 3d il ya des planches
originales il ya des vieux numéros de
tintin des vieux numéros de spirou s'est
vraiment montré la prolifération de ce
travail pendant pendant des années et
même des décennies et surtout s'est
montrée mais ce n'était pas un combat
ouvert c'était plutôt un combat culturel
où c'était voilà dans la bonne humeur
dans dans quelque chose qui a marqué des
générations c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que c'est vraiment si vous allez
voir l'exposition vous allez voir le
patrimoine de la bande dessinée à la
fois du black et mortimer du dual x du
macherot du michel vaillant du du
pays-haut voilà il ya vraiment tout
l'univers de la bande dessinée des
années 40 50 et même 70 jusqu'à 2000 on
pourra consulter certains des ouvrages
qui sont présentés il y aura les
ouvrages oui les ouvrages en
consultation il ya à peu près 90
planches originales donc voilà il ya
plein de choses à découvrir est ce qui
est très étonnant c'est dans une salle
extraordinaire qui est la galerie la
galerie de la bibliothèque donc une
salle historique et là c'était quand
même un challenge de deux mètres du neuf
dans des salles très ancien il était
difficile de réunir les différentes
pièces je pense aux origines par exemple
oui un petit peu oui mais c'est bon
c'est mon travail de trouver des pièces
lorsqu'on voit une plus une planche
originale de jacques martin dale xc
c'est magnifique c'est assez inédit de
faire ce parallèle entre ces deux sets
ça n'a pas été fait ça n'a pas été fait
il ya plus tôt on met en avant un auteur
ou quelque chose mais là c'est vraiment
c'est tout l'ensemble qui est mis en
avant vous l'avez dit on s'intéresse aux
journaux que ce soit les périodiques
tintin les périodiques spirou il y avait
des héros à l'intérieur quels sont les
héros les plus emblématiques de chacun
des deux journaux peut-être ya les
emblématiques donc forcément tintin et
spirou ça ne peut pas y échapper fister
chaque avoir pratiqué le propre revue
puis à gaston donc dans le côté spirou
mais il y avait aussi gil jourdan dans
les années 50 y avait aussi pays avec
johan et pirlouit tant du côté spirou
mais du côté atteint on avait forcément
bain
alix blake et mortimer
énormément de série aussi qui sont
sortis dans ces revues michel vaillant
ricochet voilà toutes ces séries ont les
retrouver dans ces revues et façonnent
de madère ça c'est vraiment des épisodes
ont suivi les épisodes pour avoir
histoire complète en trois quatre mois
mais est ce que les personnages de bande
dessinée passer d'un journal à l'autre
puisque les auteurs passait dans une
analyse auteurs parfois on fait ce qu'il
sait jouer la concurrence face et
évidemment pas par exemple manque un
moment est parti il a fait modeste et
pompon chez tintin puis revenue chez
spirou voilà il ya ils se sont promenés
parfois certains se sont promenés il y
en a qu'un des deux à une seule des deux
revues qui a survécu et c'est celle de
spirou c'est une revue qui se porte bien
encore aujourd'hui je suis qui se porte
bien mais il faut des prépublications et
puis y suivre leurs actualités dejiang
de l'éditeur dupuis donc il ya en avant
première le prochain tunique bleue le
prochain spirou fantasio le prochain
yoko tsuno le prochain cédric ils sont
tous là voilà il est nostalgique des
ronds toujours que c'était mieux avant
vous en faites partie ou pas c'est non
c'est pas que c'est mieux avancer
différence et c'est forcément une
évolution de la bande dessinée on peut
pas s'attendre à voir du franc cas
aujourd'hui mais moi je lis toujours un
plaisir un nouveau spirou et spiro qui
continue vous le dit avec ces nouvelles
aventures qui continue puisqu'il ya eu
un d'autres auteurs qui ont reprise est
là aussi la différence si on s'intéresse
pas aux périodiques mais au personnage
tente ans n'a pas survécu à son créateur
non c'est pas le cas pour spirou c'est
l'éditeur qui a les droits de spirou
donc l'éditeur c'est lui qui est
propriétaire donc il peut choisir quels
auteurs vont vous reprendre spirou et
donc il ya eu un grand nombre d'auteurs
qui ont repris spirou fantasio et là il
ya même plusieurs équipes qui
travaillent en même temps on sait très
intéressant il ya une série classique et
puis à les séries parallèles et c'est
plutôt d'une très bonne manufacturés au
contraire c'est même il se donne du mal
pour faire quelque chose de bien et nous
avons voulu savoir ce qui marchait le
mieux en librairie s est ce que ce sont
les bandes dessinées de tintin les
classiques même s'il n'ya pas une
nouveauté depuis une bonne vingtaine
d'années maintenant ou est ce que ce
sont les spirou qui continuent à sortir
régulièrement voici la réponse dans une
des librairies de saint quentin c'est à
montigny-le-bretonneux
tintin reste vraiment la bd phare est
classique par excellence c'est quelque
chose que je vends vraiment
dans les tomes précédents fin dans les
dom
on va tourner et c'est ce qui va ce qui
tourne le mieux par contre spirou à
chaque nouveauté
faire revenir des nouveaux publics mais
tintin c'est le classique ont à dire on
parle de tintin comme du classique c'est
une valeur sûre toujours ce n'est pas
toujours le cas sur les nouveautés
spirou qui sortent avec une qualité
régulière non mais parce qu'il ya les
neuf forcément les nostalgiques vont
dire spirou s'arrête à franquin et de
dix noms spirou continue et voilà la
série continue de son propre chef la
rivalité entre les deux héros a toujours
raison d'être quand je pense pas non
parce que tintin n'a pas ni tatin ne vit
que par cesser ses albums ses vingt
trois albums et puis voilà ça s'arrête
là et puis il ya cette exposition donc à
découvrir pour revivre ces années fastes
des deux revues des deux périodiques
tintin et spirou aujourd'hui il n'existe
plus que spirou on l'a dit on le redit
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres revues qui
pourrait voir le jour sur le même thème
qui permettent la prépublication qui
permettent de découvrir des ro c'est
faisable aujourd'hui il en existe mais
c'est plutôt intimiste on n'est plus du
tout dans les bars journal de spirou qui
continue lui continue à faire la
prépublication mais en crau grosse
concurrence ya pas eu encore des plus
adulte fille lila ciel qui continue
depuis des années pilote a disparu à
suivre a disparu les grands classiques
d'autres vues se sont essayé pendant un
certain temps mais pour l'instant il ya
en revue généraliste classique
spécialisé auprès d'un éditeur n'y en a
pas et ça s'explique comment c'est le
marché qui veut ça aujourd'hui
l'évolution du marché numérique
l'ensemble
l'ensemble des lecteurs qui a un peu
changé il ya plus du tout le même
électorat dans les années 50 que les
jours d'huile surtout dans la jeunesse
tu atteins spirou match retour 20 avril
à 13 juillet bibliothèque municipale de
versailles les coordonnées se sont
affichés vous pouvez forcément vous y
rendre à partir de ce week end il y aura
un ouvrage une édition qui sera tiré à
l'occasion de ce qu'il y aura un petit
catalogue très intimiste donc il faudra
se dépêcher cet ep chez pour sa voiture
et vous ne partez pas je vais vous poser
la question si c'est possible de
récupérer quelques uns merci à vous